le week-end dernier un salarié de l'itep
de maîtresse est suicidé par arme à feu
sur son lieu de travail devant deux de
ses collègues il venait d'apprendre son
licenciement
une enquête a été ouverte pour tenter
d'éclaircir les causes exactes de ce
geste théodore de quiros a recueilli le
témoignage du directeur de l'entreprise
ainsi que celui d'une ancienne collègue
de travail
quelques jours après son acte c'est
l'incompréhension dans cette association
d'insertion salariés depuis 2014 cet
ancien chef de service de 50 ans il est
aussi délégué syndical depuis plus de
deux ans à la suite d'une enquête
interne le directeur engage une
procédure de licenciement pour faute
grave début 2000 22
l'inspection du travail la valide
vendredi dernier il était dit que
il fallait que l'association
l'employeur et donc son directeur
général prenne des mesures rapides pour
éloigner définitivement ce salarié julie
travaille cinq ans sous l'autorité du
quinquagénaire à leur chef du pôle
hébergement d'un autre centre pour elle
le portrait dressé dans le rapport
interne celui d'un homme responsable de
souffrance et d'anxiété au travail ne
lui correspond pas du tout et des zones
d'ombré planent sur son licenciement sur
la personne qu'on décrit en fait moi
c'est pas la personne que je connaissais
c'était pas quelqu'un d'isolé ce qui me
dérange c'est qu'on attribue l'entière
faute ou en tout cas une grosse partie
de la faute à un homme une enquête
autour des circonstances de sa mort a
été ouverte par la gendarmerie et des
auditions des témoins doivent être
réalisés